Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was lesen wir im nächsten Salon? Was machen wir im Sommer und überhaupt, was ist hier los?
Am 23. August kann man uns live erleben in Frankfurt. Dort ist das große Sommerevent. Wir beide präsentieren dann was genau, das verraten wir noch nicht. Jedenfalls werden wir auch ein paar Fragen aus dem Publikum ermöglichen. Da haben wir uns ja auch schon überlegt, wie wir das gestalten. Jedenfalls ist das das große Podcast-Sommer-Event. Wer das erleben will, kann das immer noch tun. Denn es gibt noch Karten, die findet man auch diesmal direkt auf der Homepage. Kann sich also im Saalplan durchklicken, wo man gerne sitzen möchte. Das findet man, wenn man auf die Seite der CASE in Frankfurt geht, dann zum 23. August scrollt. Und dort findet man dann unsere Veranstaltung. Also das ist das große Sommerevent. Natürlich sind wir auch davor und danach dann da und auch ansprechbar, da legen wir Wert drauf. Wer also da Zeit und Lust hat, kann gern kommen. Wir freuen uns. Und wir wollen natürlich uns hier ganz kurz in Erinnerung rufen, dass wir ein Podcast machen, in dem wir noch Bücher lesen. Und so wird es auch im nächsten Salon sein. Wir haben uns für ein Buch erschienen, das, wie ich gerade merke, wunderbar zu meiner Krawatte passt farblich. Inhaltlich weiß ich es noch nicht. Jedenfalls heißt es Geoökonomie. Anatomie der Neuen Weltordnung von Milan Babic. Das Buch ist bei Surkamp erschienen. Und gleich auf der Klappe lesen wir, die Welt der neoliberalen Globalisierung ist nicht länger unsere Wirklichkeit. Das Verhältnis von Staat, Markt und Politik muss fundamental neu gedacht werden. Der Begriff der Geoökonomie soll dazu einen Beitrag leisten. Das heißt also ein neuer Grundbegriff wird hier eingeführt und wir sind gespannt, was dieser Professor für Politische Ökonomie an der Uni Amsterdam uns dazu zu sagen hat.
Ja, es ist ganz interessant, dass man sofort erfährt, also ich weiß natürlich nicht, ob das jetzt der Klappentext ist oder nicht, aber zumindest der Ankündigungstext auf der Webseite. Geoökonomie, wir kennen ja Geopolitik und hier wird sehr viel Wert draufgelegt, dass trotz aller Verwerfungen die Unternehmen im Zentrum oder zentrale Akteure bleiben. Und wir sind ja eh erpicht darauf, Zäsuren nicht zu verpassen. Es könnte sein, dass das, was wir gerade an politischen Verwerfungen sehen, während wir aber vor die Haustür gehen und sehen, der Supermarkt ist noch bestückt wie vorher, könnte sich jetzt in Amerika ein bisschen ändern, aber noch ist es ja eine Diskrepanz zwischen medialem Erleben und so privaten Leben einfach. Und die muss ja mal wieder eingefangen werden.
Ja.
Und wenn wir in zwei Jahren feststellen, ah ja, wir lächeln immer so über den neuen Papst, weil Papst, who cares, ich bin kein Katholik. Und gleichzeitig nehmen wir aber Politiker ganz ernst. Und vielleicht ändert sich das demnächst, ja, dass wir wieder feststellen, wow, der Papst hat mir echt was zu sagen. Der hat so Expertise, der sagt was zu Sachen, die mich interessieren und so weiter und so fort. Das kann ich mir bei Trump gar nicht vorstellen. Und bei Merz habe ich es in den ersten Jahren auch nicht erlebt. So. Also wir sind hier auf der Suche nach Zäsuren und haben ein Textangebot, das uns da wieder entgegenkommt, glaube ich. Ob es dann hält, werden wir sehen. Aber das Versprechen ist schon mal da.
Du hast ja schon das andere Wort genannt, das so viel jetzt in aller Munde war. Geopolitik. Und wir haben ja auch schon mal über Mörscheimer sehr ausführlich gesprochen, wie er sich also diese Machtblöcke vorstellt. Und da wird ja eigentlich das Ökonomische ausgeklamert. Ich unterhiet mich jetzt kürzlich mit einem Historiker, der sich sehr mit Ostpolitik und all dem auskennt. Und der sagte dann, ja, Mörscheimer, der ist schon ganz interessant. Aber eigentlich auch da hat er seine Schwächen ganz klar, wo er nicht mal willens ist, das Politökonomische eigentlich hineinzudenken. Denn das spielt ja nun auch eine große Rolle. Gerade, wenn man auf Russland, Ukraine, EU, USA blickt. Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, es gibt da so einen Rohstoffdeal, von dem wir alle noch nicht so genau wissen, wie sieht denn das da eigentlich aus? Wir wissen schon, die EU hat ja gerade zu Sorge, wenn wirklich die Ukraine Mitglied werden würde. Du hast das immer betont. Dann würden ja 40% der Agrarsubventionen plötzlich an die Ukraine gehen. Also auch das sind Überlegungen.
Und dann mit 30% des Budgets.
Ja, und was ist eigentlich mit der Ukraine, die so ein starkes Land war? Ja, erst wirklich als ein Land galt, wo sich das jetzt alles ganz schnell mit dem Kapitalismus entwickeln würde. Und dann war sie plötzlich ganz abgehängt. Anders, eine völlig andere Geschichte genommen als beispielsweise Polen. Und ist dann das zweitärmste, je nach Berechnung das ärmste Land Europas geworden. Also plötzlich geht es doch wieder so wahnsinnig viel um Ökonomie. Und naja, und Apple, die Chips und China. Wo sind wir dann da? Insofern glaube ich, ist also dieser Begriff Geoökonomie einer, der einen ein bisschen aus dem geopolitischen Denken herauslösen könnte. Also wo man nur diese Machtpolitik sieht. Und zugleich sind es natürlich die Staaten, die auch eine Rolle spielen. Das deutet sich ja in der Weise, dass sie natürlich den Rahmen setzen für die Märkte oder die Unternehmen, die darin agieren.
Ja, wenn politische Macht mit Geld codiert ist, dann kommen wir eh in Teufels Küche. Also wenn es da, typischerweise spricht man von Korruption, wenn wir hören, dass Donald Trump sich irgendwelche Flugzeuge schenken lässt und so. Nur wenn wir feststellen, dass im ganz großen Bild China überhaupt nur für uns so nervenaufreibend ist, weil da einfach Ökonomie so ne große Rolle spielt. Also das eigentlich so Sekundäre die Hauptrolle spielt. Dann wirds brenzlig, dann brauchen wir auch neue Theorie. Also das Buch ist sehr einladend. Ich glaube, wir finden da einiges zum diskutieren.
Wunderbar. Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, dass das ja die einzige Möglichkeit ist, den Podcast zu unterstützen, nämlich ein Abonnement abzuschließen für den Salon. Wir freuen uns sehr, wenn das mehr Leute tun und uns zuhören wollen, wie wir über Bücher diskutieren, aber uns dann auch und natürlich allen, die zuhören, Artikel empfehlen. Also wir versuchen tatsächlich, die Lektüre hochzuhalten. Und wer also diesen unabhängigen Podcasts unterstützen will, kann das am besten tun mit einem Abonnement. Das geht über Steady, Apple und Patreon.
So ist es. Wir legen noch Werte darauf, dass Menschen Texte von Menschen lesen, obwohl, glaube ich, unbestreitbar ist, dass zumindest ich auch ein großer KI-Fan bin.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber wir ziehen jetzt hier neue, also wir ziehen grundsätzlich Paratikmen ein. Wir werden Ende des Monats auch sehr, sehr ausführlich über den Papst reden.
Und das kommt von dir. Das ist nicht mein Vorschlag.
Genau, das kommt von mir, um uns auch zu verdeutlichen, was Google bei der Entwicklerkonferenz IO so vorstellt. Denn klar kann man das einfach runter rattern, aber wir müssen das jetzt wirklich spontan historisieren, was hier geschieht. Es gibt die großen Ansagen aus dem Silicon Valley und des Vatikans. Es stellen sich ganz neue Dichotomien auf in dieser Welt.
Und ich möchte vielleicht noch einen Hinweis darauf machen, dass wir ja über Abundance gesprochen haben, das Buch von Esra Klein und Derek Thompson. Das ist ja ein Buch, das sagt, wir müssen bauen. Wir müssen eigentlich jetzt konstruktiv sein und nicht jetzt nur gucken, wo können wir umverteilen, wo können wir sparen oder sonst was. Wir erleben jetzt hier in Deutschland wieder eine reine Debatte um, wo kann man sparen. Das ist wirklich ganz absurd. Man hatte ja dann kurz gedacht, okay, im Zuge der Aufrüstungsdebatte und im Zuge dieses Schuldenpakets gibt es dann auch ein wirkliches Umdenken, aber das scheint nicht der Fall zu sein. Insofern ist das ein Buch, mit dem man sich auch jetzt wappnen könnte einmal, also um auch sich ein paar Inspirationen zu holen, was eigentlich möglich wäre, auch für eine danach folgende Politik oder was man vielleicht auch anbieten müsste, um diesen Rechtsruck, der ja immer weiter zunimmt, zu verhindern. Also nochmal einen ganz klaren Hinweis auf diesen Salon. Wir waren uns nicht einig in der Bewertung des Buches an sich. Dir hat es besser gefallen als mir, sagen wir mal so. Aber in der Sache waren wir uns dann doch sehr einig, dass dort die entscheidenden Themen angesprochen werden und dass auch mal wieder Angebote gemacht werden. Es hilft ja nicht, wenn wir die ganze Zeit nur so Debatten führen, wie retten wir die Demokratie, wenn aber das Angebot der Demokratie mit der Lupe gesucht werden muss. Und das ist deswegen nochmal ein sehr wichtiges Buch. Und ich darf verkündigt, weiß nicht, ob du schon mitbekommen hast, wir haben ja, ich glaube, es war im Oktober Salon 2023 oder 24, 24 muss es gewesen sein, nee 23, ich bin mir unsicher, über, man muss es nachschauen, über Neo Ragazzi gesprochen, das Talk-Format von Tommy Schmidt und Sophie Passmann und heute die Meldung, es wird eingestellt.
Juhu, oder was?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also wir waren ja nicht begeistert davon. Also ich bin, ich sag mal so, man, ich traue mich heute auch kaum noch zu jubeln, weil man ja nie weiß, was danach passiert. Oftmals wird es auch nicht besser.
Eben, eben, eben. Deswegen verbuchen wir das einfach als, es ist geschehen und es wird anderes passieren. Mal gucken, wie es im Fernsehen, nein, wir interessieren uns nicht fürs Fernsehen.
Nein, wir jetzt erstmal nicht. Vielleicht dann bald wieder. Also, Geoökonomie erschienen bei Suhrkamp. Darüber sprechen wir dann, aber zunächst mal hören wir uns ja dann und sehen uns vielleicht am Ende des Monats zur üblichen Folge. Und die Live-Show, die wir dann im Juni machen, die ist ausverkauft, soweit ich weiß. Aber wie gesagt, im Sommer für den 23. August gibt es noch Karten.
Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns am Ende des Monats, wenn wir ein paar Glaubensgrundsätze klären. Bis dahin.
Bis dann.